Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea makers...
We can really change the world
together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones
who determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator: We celebrate
entrepreneurs.
I want you all to think,
"Who's next?"
Narrator: This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Rohan Oza,
the branding guru behind
some of the world's
most successful
consumer products,
joins the Tank.
I always look for stuff
that is breaking the mold
of what's out there today.
So we are
a little more expensive.
I'm gonna go out!
It drives me bonkers.
You want
a participation trophy.
What we have here
is not yet a business.
I have put my blood, sweat,
and tears into this.
I love these guys!
Oza: I'd like to give you
an offer,
but you may not like it.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a product
to help you survive the most
crucial hours of an emergency.
♪♪
Corcoran: Yep.
These are my type.
[ Laughs ]
Mountaineers.
You're ‐‐
You're rough.
Mountaineers.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Christian Schauf.
And I'm Mike Escamilla.
We're asking for $100,000 in
exchange for 5% of our company
Uncharted Supply Company.
[ Rumbling ]
‐Whoa!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my God!
‐Fancy Moses!
Oza: Shut the front door!
Is this the big one?
It was the big one.
Hopefully that was
the big one.
Sharks, our world ‐‐
It's changing.
Emergency situations,
like earthquakes
and natural disasters,
are on the rise.
With growing population,
it's getting harder and harder
for first responders and
emergency personnel to keep up.
Schauf: That's true, and while
95% of all survival situations
are resolved in 72 hours,
what you do
in those first 72 hours
can be the difference
between life and death.
And we have a solution
for that.
We got to clean up
a little bit here.
I didn't like that picture,
anyways.
That's the way
I clean up, too.
[ Chuckles ]
Introducing the Seventy2.
♪♪
This is over 35
high‐quality tools
and information
to help you survive and thrive
in literally hundreds
of situations ‐‐
everything from air filtration,
food, to shelter.
This bag, honestly,
it has everything you need.
It is the smartest product
on the market,
all at a price point
nearly anyone can afford.
We designed this to educate,
equip, and prepare people
for whatever life
throws their way.
This is the Seventy2.
Do you want
to give them samples?
We've got some samples for
you guys we'd like to hand out.
All right.
[ Chuckles ]
Here we go.
Cuban: Oh, cool.
Real samples.
‐Oh, Wow. This is fantastic.
‐Oh, I love this.
This is the best goodie bag
I've received in a long time.
‐Here you go.
‐Thank you!
This is actually
two products here.
We'll get
to this one next.
Whew!
Barbara, I know what you're
getting for Christmas.
‐Here you go.
‐Thank you.
Herjavec: Christian,
are you saying everything
on that board
is in here?
Yeah.
Yes.
Tell us some of the key safety
items that are in the bag.
This is a bit
of a transformer.
Everything works
to work together.
So there's not one thing
that really makes a difference.
It's having the right things
for whatever happens.
One of the things a lot
of people don't have is ‐‐
is, like,
this is an even power ‐‐
uh, power bank.
So that is a crank radio,
flashlight,
and it'll charge your cellphone.
What's your background?
I started the company.
I‐I grew up on a dairy farm
in Wisconsin.
So I‐I've lived
a life outside,
where you prepare
for the day,
and you take care of yourself,
right?
And I moved to L. A.
a few years ago
and it sprinkled one day
and the whole world stopped.
‐L.A.'s very delicate.
‐Oh, man.
This guy's from LA,
so he hates when I tell this,
but it's ‐‐ this is where
the idea really came from.
[ Laughs ]
I‐I thought if ‐‐
if rain is gonna stop everybody
in their tracks, what happens
if an earthquake hits?
So I started researching
a product
that I thought
would protect me.
Everything on the market,
it's just not ‐‐
The right thing
isn't there.
It's almost dangerous
because you think you're buying
something to prepare yourself,
and what's in there ‐‐
Isn't gonna work.
It's not ‐‐
It's not gonna work,
and even if it does work,
you don't know how to use it.
Right.
Especially ‐‐
The good thing about this
is it has
all the directions printed
on how to use it,
what order to use in it,
color‐coordinated
to the pockets inside
'cause, you know,
when it's an emergency happens,
it's ‐‐ it's kind of frantic.
You know, it's gnarly.
Herjavec: I like the idea.
It's a great idea.
People never
think about bad crap happening
until bad crap happens.
Yeah.
Can you break out the numbers
for me?
What are your sales?
We started
about six months ago selling.
We've sold $700,000
so far.
‐In six months?!
‐Wow.
‐To 64 countries.
We did a crowdfunding campaign
to start.
How much did you do
in crowdfunding?
Uh, we did about $400,000
in the first month.
Wow.
And then we ‐‐ Everything else
has been through our website.
Wow!
Give me an idea
of what yours costs
and what are the average ones
on the market.
So, we are
a little more expensive.
Ours is $350, okay?
That's not bad.
Um...
And what ‐‐
And what do you make it for?
Our first round ‐‐
They cost us $209 apiece to make
because we were really concerned
about making the right product.
Wow.
But in six months, we've gotten
that price down to $141.
‐Oh, that's good.
‐And we know we can do better.
So, you guys have got
to be making
a boatload of money,
right?
I think we're gonna make
$250,000, $300,000
this first year,
but I‐I haven't taken a penny.
So you're making $300,000
in gross margin, basically.
Right.
We just bought 3,000 units.
Why so many units
at a time?
What's your lead time?
And where are you
making them?
We are, on the grand scale
of things,
a small player
with these big factories, right?
So the factories said, "We'll
have your product in 30 days."
It ended up being 90 days.
We assemble these
in the United States
at a company called PRAC
that hires handicapped people
and gives them jobs.
Oh, great.
So we found
a really cool solution there,
and we feel really good
about that.
I think you guys
are so authentic.
Thank you.
I mean, you're, like,
out of Central Casting.
Pick these guys ‐‐
Barbara likes you
for other reasons, too.
Yeah, there's ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
No, no, that's not true.
I know you might be
attracted to me,
but I am a married woman.
[ Laughter ]
‐Just for the record.
‐Yeah.
But I'm married to a guy
that has a fire extinguisher
in the four corners
of every room I live in.
So he's, like,
right on this kind of stuff.
He's really hoping
for doomsday.
I think I'm gonna buy one
for Bill
and let the other guys
take your deal.
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Guys, I‐I don't ‐‐
I don't think you need
a lot more than the cash,
and I don't like being
dumb money.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
Herjavec: So, guys,
I'm sitting here,
I'm thinking
all the executional challenges,
operational challenges,
but you'll figure it out.
I do think you need
a little more money.
You're looking for $100,000
for 5%.
Here's my offer.
I'll give you $200,000
for 10%.
Oh, thank you.
Same valuation,
more money.
Do we have a deal?
Well, they want to hear
what we have to say.
Schauf: I mean, yeah.
Well, maybe they do,
maybe they don't.
I don't want to get
into a bidding war with people.
I'd love to do business
with you.
$200,000 for 10%,
or you can move on
to the other Sharks.
I'm happy to sit out,
or I'm happy to do a deal
right now.
I mean,
that is very attractive to me.
I would just love to see
what everybody else has to say.
That is ‐‐ That is right
what we're looking for.
‐You have an exploding offer.
‐I'm gonna go out.
Start dancing.
I'm gonna go out.
Listen.
He's gonna go out.
Going once...
I ‐‐
Going twice...
Christian?
I'm gonna tell you
what I'm gonna say.
Okay, okay.
‐What?
‐He took it! He took it!
I love your product
as much ‐‐
We have a deal.
$200,000 at 10%!
Oh, no!
Don't! Don't!
That just happened.
Yeah. Yeah.
‐No! No! Listen to me!
‐That just happened.
Greiner: I was just gonna
give you an offer.
Thank you very much.
That was faster
than I thought.
I trained Robert well.
Oh, my God.
You have to go fa‐‐
I'm sorry.
I had to make a decision.
I was trying to talk.
Cuban: Hey, guys,
in nine years,
that's the first time
he's been able to pull that off.
‐I love your product.
‐Thank you.
‐Oh, my God.
♪♪
‐Bloody awful!
‐That was the best.
‐I love these guys.
‐Awful.
‐No, they're great.
[ Chuckles ]
That was a usurping
right there.
Herjavec: Ooh!
Oh, no, I would have blown it up
amongst women.
I would have done
a lot with it.
Lori, the reason I wanted
to do that
was I knew exactly
where you were gonna go,
and that is the big market
for it.
If you can get women to buy it
and put them in every house ‐‐
Yeah, but, Robert, how are you
gonna get women to buy it?
Well, he's gonna come
to you.
Right?
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Oza: I was born and raised
in a small town
called Livingstone
in Zambia, Africa.
I'm a third‐generation African,
but culturally Indian.
Education is critically
important in the Indian culture.
That's the way we believe
we can strive.
we can succeed.
My passion is building brands
in a disruptive way.
I graduated from Michigan,
and the first company I went
to work for was Coca‐Cola.
I got to work
on Sprite and Powerade,
where I learned
lifestyle marketing.
I realized
that corporate America
really wasn't for me.
I decided to leave Coke
and become a partner
in a company
that no one had heard of
called Vitaminwater.
People thought I was crazy.
Who gives up a great career
at Coke for an unknown start‐up?
But people were looking
for a brand like Vitaminwater.
Sodas was too much sugar.
The brand just blew up
and became part of pop culture.
The irony of the whole thing
is we actually ended up
selling Vitaminwater
and Smartwater
back to Coca‐Cola
for $4.1 billion.
I became a serial
investor‐entrepreneur.
Popchips, Vita Coco, Chef's Cut,
Sir Kensington's Ketchup, Bai.
Bai we sold for $1.7 billion.
People who want
to make a difference
are always going
to have pushback.
You have to have the inner
confidence to push through
because if you don't break
through that wall,
you'll get stuck behind it.
Consumers walk by. They've got
three seconds to decide.
Building a brand
is not just about marketing.
You have to start with a product
that people really need.
You then need to have people
that have the right passion.
And then you bring the marketing
and the buzz.
And all that, to me,
is brand building.
I've never had
an original product idea,
but what I have an ability to do
is, very early,
find amazing products
created by amazing people.
And I help take those brands
to the promised land.
♪♪
It's known as the American Dream
because people can come here,
start with nothing,
have a great idea,
and build it
into something special.
When I look out at the city
and think back to the small town
I grew up in
and where I am today,
it's crazy.
I'm both humbled and proud
of what I've done
to get here.
♪♪
Our business was inspired
by our son Jackson.
Jackson's the oldest
of our four kids.
He was born healthy.
He was walking and talking.
Scott: But after Jackson's
first birthday,
he started to develop
some muscle weakness
that gradually spread
up his body.
He developed
some GI distress,
and he was crying
almost all the time.
We took Jackson to specialists
around the country
and still weren't able
to find any answers.
We made the large assumption
that it was something
inflammatory‐based.
And by process
of elimination,
we found what helped Jackson
was more fats and less carbs.
He started sleeping
through the night.
He started gaining weight.
And then we knew we had stumbled
on something
critical
to his health.
Do you want to try it?
Jackson's finally received
a diagnosis.
He has a rare
autoimmune disease
called
Aicardi‐Goutieres Syndrome.
And he's one of seven kids
in the world
with this variant
of this rare disorder.
Jackson!
Scott: Whether or not
we find a cure,
the one thing
we can be sure of
is that we're never,
ever going to give up.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Megan Reamer.
And I'm her husband,
Scott.
We're here
from Crested Butte, Colorado.
We're asking
for $1.25 million
for 5% of our business
Jackson's Honest.
Yes, sir!
We are on a mission
to fundamentally disrupt
the $20 billion
snack‐food industry.
We make the most delicious
potato and tortilla chips
cooked in 100% organic
coconut oil.
Coconut oil
is a super food
with a wide array
of health benefits.
It's a great source
of plant‐based healthy fats.
It's easy to digest.
And it's a great oil
to cook with
because it's stable
when you heat it.
We learned a lot about the
benefits of coconut oil
when caring
for our son Jackson.
Jackson became very sick
with a rare disease,
and over many years
of trial and error,
we realized that a low‐carb,
high‐fat diet
really helped
his condition.
Coconut oil played
such a profoundly important role
in Jackson's diet
and our lives
that we started making
everything with it at home,
tortilla and potato chips
included.
And we'd give these chips
to our friends and family
and they all insisted that they
were the best they'd ever had
and, for years,
encouraged us to sell 'em.
So we did just that.
We founded Jackson's Honest
with the mission
to reintroduce this healthy fat
back to the snack aisle.
We're gonna
pass out samples.
‐Oh.
‐Oh, thank you.
I love chips.
Awesome.
All right. Lovely.
Thank you.
Here,
I'll give this to Barb.
Could you hand us
the packaging, too,
from any of them
so we get...
I have to say, these are
absolutely delicious.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank you.
Blimey.
This is the best chip.
All I need is a beer.
[ Chuckles ]
Scott, is your background
in food?
No, it's not, actually.
[ Chuckles ]
You know, we ‐‐
we made these
just to fill a need
in our house.
I have an undergraduate degree
in chemical engineering,
so I understood
at least some of the chemistry,
but the reality was
my position as a father
and Megan's as a mother
is what drove us to find this.
I remember when my son
was a year and a half old
and he needed to go
to the hospital
and they had
to do an operation with him,
and I realize I can't go in
with him.
I mean, to this day,
it is crystal clear
in my mind and my eyes.
Like, I ‐‐ I see it
right here.
So I can imagine
that level of pain,
and then to churn that into
this incredible ‐‐
not just story ‐‐
but an actual company,
I mean, power to you.
Thank you.
Thank ‐‐ thank you.
You have more courage
than I did...
Thank you.
...and that's very admirable.
Um...great packaging,
great branding.
That's my job in life ‐‐
to make women cry.
[ Chuckles ]
Well...
Usually does it
for other reasons, but...
[ Laughter ]
'Scuse me, I'm sorry.
I, uh...
Don't apologize.
You know, it's just ‐‐
it's...it's turning
something ‐‐
like lemons into lemonade
and turning
this very difficult experience
into something
really positive.
Let me start by commending you
on a product
that is absolutely disrupting
the food and beverage base.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
for saying that.
I always look for stuff
that is breaking the mold
of what's out there today.
Everything out there
is high sugar, high fat ‐‐
not the good stuff
that you need.
You're bringing
the good fats in.
So I'd like to change gears
a little bit now
because ‐‐
to the finance component,
'cause you're here
for money...
Sure.
...and my rudimentary
mathematics ‐‐
I'm Indian, so it's actually
a little more than rudimentary.
We have to be good
at math.
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
Culturally, we have
to be good at math.
Wow.
So, this is
worth $25 million
is what you are valuing
the company at.
That's correct.
So that's a hefty valuation.
It is.
Walk me through that,
and how did you get there?
Tell us about the sales.
Last year,
it was $10.1 million.
‐There you go.
‐Wow.
What'd you do
the year before?
Year before
was $5.4 million.
And the year before?
And before that,
$1.4 million.
Are you profitable?
Not yet.
Okay,
how much are you losing?
We lost, last year,
about $1.7 million.
‐Why is that?
‐Whew.
Producing these chips ‐‐
It's an expensive game.
Yeah. Food,
as a general rule of thumb,
is a difficult business
from a margin standpoint.
It takes a lot of money
to produce products.
What's your margin
on these?
But why were you losing
that much money last year?
Because we grew
so fast.
Yes.
So getting shelf space
is actually
quite an expensive endeavor.
‐You paid slotting fees ‐‐
‐Uh, but that's okay.
‐So...
‐Well, hang on.
You got to explain that
to us.
But ‐‐ but did you have
to pay slotting fees?
Scott: Sure.
But, in a natural channel,
it's not slotting fees,
it's free fill.
So we give away, literally,
cases of our product...
Greiner: Right.
...in order to gain
that shelf space.
What does that add
to your costs?
Last year,
it was about 18%...
Corcoran: That's huge.
...18.4% ‐‐ very large.
That's huge.
So it's like giving
one out of five bags free
to stay in the door.
So, at what point,
do you become profitable?
Next year, actually.
Pretty soon, actually.
Really, we're really close.
Yes, we've got it
modeled out.
Where's the rest
of the costs?
Sure.
Like, I understand
the lower margin.
Look at me ‐‐ I love the chips.
I've got all of ‐‐
Yeah.
It's always better not to talk
with your mouth full.
Why don't you swallow first?
You got it
all over your face.
So, while he's chewing ‐‐
guys, while he's chewing,
guys, how much money
have you raised,
if any, for this company?
We've ‐‐ from friends
and family,
we've raised in equity
$3 million.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Whoo!
Wow.
So, how much of the company
do you still own?
Two‐thirds.
Two‐thirds, okay.
This year,
what's the forecast?
Uh, the ‐‐ we have
between $13 million
and $14 million run rate
right now for this year.
So, run rate means you're doing
about $1 million a month?
$1 million ‐‐
We just had our largest,
uh, month ever in May ‐‐
$1.42 million.
Wow.
Oza: So, I was involved
in a ‐‐
in a brand
called Popchips.
Yes.
And Popchips
had growth rates from ‐‐
you know,
we did 1.4‐ish to 4, 5,
so similar to you...
Yes.
...then we were at a 17...
...and then we're at a 45.
Yeah.
So...
But how much did you spend
on marketing?
We spent a fair bit
on marketing,
but ‐‐ but here I saw ‐‐
I like the 1.45.
I like that to the 10.
Why am I not going
10 to 20 here?
Where's ‐‐
why am I going 10 to 12, 13?
Frankly, we had to pump
the brakes a little bit.
Yes.
You know, there ‐‐
you know,
this is a difficult business
to run.
Your biggest customer,
Whole Foods?
That's correct.
Correct.
So, of the $12 million,
$13 million expected to do
this year,
how big do you think
Whole Foods would be?
Whole Foods would be
approximately 13% of that.
‐13%?
That's it?
Doing only, um, $1.5 million
at Whole Foods three years in,
that number doesn't strike me
as exciting.
I'm concerned.
Whole Foods,
the number‐one
natural player ‐‐
what's going on here?
There are lots of
other competitors out there,
and frankly,
it's one of the risks here.
Herjavec:
Let me start things off.
At a $25 million valuation,
I see more risk
than opportunity.
Not for me. I'm out.
Thank you.
So, you know, I love chips,
but I'm the person
that buys the baked chips.
Yes.
Sorry. I'm out.
Understood.
Okay. Thank you.
Cuban: So, guys,
congratulations.
What you've been able
to accomplished is amazing.
All of us are entrepreneurs,
and we know the grind.
We want you to succeed,
but, you know,
the numbers matter.
And it's
a $25 million valuation ‐‐
that's literally
how much you have to produce
in profits in order
to return my investment.
I don't see the margins
growing quick enough,
and so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
You know, there's nothing,
uh, more powerful
than a business that's birthed
out of a real‐life need
and from which a great idea
came from
and the passion
that made it run, you know?
Mm‐hmm.
But the grocery space
is notorious
for eating businesses alive.
Yeah.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Understood. Thank you.
Thank you, Barbara.
Look, I think you guys
have done a great job.
You know, but I ‐‐
but I have concerns.
I struggle mostly
with the valuation.
Yeah.
And as my venerable Sharks
have said in the past,
you've got to value
the Tank.
You know, I ‐‐ I bring
some of the most,
you know, extensive food and
beverage experience out there.
So for me,
I'd like to give you an offer,
but you may not like it.
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Rohan Oza is interested
in Jackson's Honest,
a coconut oil‐based
chip company,
but he's concerned
about the high valuation.
Megan and Scott, $1.25 million
is a lot of money,
and I feel that the amount of
equity that I'm getting for that
needs to be a lot higher.
But I also feel the value
I bring
will justify
what I'm asking for.
The 5% is way too low.
It needs to be more like 20%.
20%?
20%.
So he wants to take the
valuation from $25 million...
Sure. Exactly.
...to $6.25 million.
So let me explain a little bit
if you understand why...
Yeah.
...because every company
I've been involved in,
I was never the founder.
I'm just not that smart.
But what I am good at doing
is partnering
with really smart founders
with creative,
fantastic products
and exploding them.
You know what else
you're really good at?
Making lowball offers.
That's a very difficult offer
to entertain,
because we have done so much
in such a difficult space,
as you know.
It also means
when you raise your next round,
you have no equity left.
I‐I‐It...
Scott, make a counter.
Well, I...
What would you like to do?
How about $1.25 million
for 7.5%?
♪♪
You know, when I got involved
in Popchips,
we went from $4 million
when I got in
to $80 million
in three years.
My feeling has always been
it's better to own,
you know,
25% of a mega‐company
than it is to own
40% of a bale of hay.
But, Rohan, how much money
did you spend on marketing
to get from $4 million
to $80 million?
In order to accomplish
what you like ‐‐
what you would like
to accomplish,
he's gonna have to raise
a lot more money.
We know we need
to raise more, agreed.
Yeah.
We can go raise more
at a much better valuation
from all the people
that I know in the industry
who would love to come
into a product like this,
but we need to get
that growth rate back up.
We've got to start getting some
velocities at Whole Foods ‐‐
Ro, are you gonna counter,
or are you sticking to your 20%?
Well, you're schmoozing them up
for another 10 minutes.
I love it at 17.5%.
Ooh.
Sorry, we can't do 17.5%.
17.5% is too steep
for you?
It's too steep.
What are you guys gonna do?
♪♪
Rohan, would you accept
$1.25 million at 10%?
You and us together could make
Jackson's Honest a brand
that everybody knows about
inside of a year.
At 10%,
that's a big vic.
That's a big number.
♪♪
I like you guys,
I like your background.
I usually don't even come off
my 20%,
'cause I know the value
that I add, um...
All right, my final offer is ‐‐
is 15% for the $1.25 million.
♪♪
[ Both whispering indistinctly ]
Rohan, we'd love
to take your offer.
‐Astounding.
‐Oh, thank God.
‐Congratulations.
‐Chip of the day.
‐Congrats, also.
Thank you.
Let's go do this.
I love your product.
It's terrific.
Thank you so much.
All right, great job.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you so much
for your time.
Thank you.
Good job, Rohan.
Good job.
Scott: Rohan increases
the chances,
the probability that we're gonna
be a national brand
that everyone's gonna be
talking about.
I‐I mean, I can't even explain
what that means to us
personally, as parents,
but also as entrepreneurs.
It's an incredibly
emotional moment.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a better way to engage
and be heard
in a group setting.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
[ Whistle blows ]
Cox: Listen up, Sharks.
My name is Shane Cox.
I live
in Raleigh, North Carolina,
and I'm the creator
of the Qball.
Now, I'm here seeking
a $200,000 investment
in exchange for 15% equity
in my company.
And now, this is the Qball.
But it's not just
an ordinary ball.
It's actually
[echoing] a wireless microphone!
Oh, wow.
Oh, snap.
[ Normal voice ]
So, Qball is a fun...
Snap.
...and dynamic way
to engage
and interact with others.
You can toss it,
you can roll it,
and, yes,
you can drop this mic.
[ Chuckles ]
Which is why
it's the perfect tool
for the classroom.
Now, students absolutely love
the Qball
because it makes learning
both fun and interactive.
Teachers love it
because it helps them
manage classroom discussions,
because if you have
the ball,
then you have
the floor.
Most importantly,
we make sure that every student
can be heard.
But it's not just
for the classroom.
The next time
that you're at an event
and you want everybody to hear
that audience member's question,
just toss 'em a Qball.
Our system
is simple to set up
and works with anything
from pro audio systems
to plain, old
desktop speakers.
So tell me, Sharks ‐‐
who's ready to get
the ball rolling with the Qball?
Mark's hands were up first,
so...
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Hello.
Herjavec: [ Chuckles ]
Bum, bum, bum.
So, what is it connected to?
Like, how does it ‐‐
So, the way that it works is,
uh, is a little receiver here ‐‐
comes with the system ‐‐
and that connects
into your audio system.
It's just
a regular audio output,
so you could plug it into
the auxiliary input in your car,
you can plug it into,
like I said, desktop speakers.
‐So, some speakers.
‐Some sort of speakers.
Greiner: Do we get samples?
That's the only one
that's up and working,
but you can at least get the ‐‐
the feel of it.
Thank you.
Herjavec: What's the main reason
I would buy this?
Cox: So the primary application
is actually for the classroom.
There's a lot of studies
that have been done
on acoustics
in the classroom.
So, as an adult,
if Mark's saying something
and I miss every third word,
I can fill in the blanks.
Kids, they don't fill
in the blanks.
Cognitive auditory processing
doesn't develop
until you're 15 years old.
Hmm.
How much does it cost?
What's the price of one?
So, it's $179
is the retail price on it.
Wow.
And what does it cost you
to make it?
So, it costs us $52 landed.
$52?
Have you sold any, Shane?
Yep. So year to date,
we've done $177,000.
‐Well, that's great.
‐All your sales are to schools?
Probably 90%.
We have some church groups,
we have some public speakers.
I'm a one‐man show,
so all the sales ‐‐
that $177,000 ‐‐
that's me working trade shows.
That's...
Wow. Do you have a patent?
I do have a patent pending.
Um, it's all about ‐‐
so...I don't know
if you noticed,
when I throw it, you don't
actually hear any noise.
So it's got sensors.
It knows
when it's being thrown
and it puts itself to sleep,
basically.
Clever.
I guess here's
where I'm struggling.
I think it's a great idea
for classrooms,
but short of calling
on every single school,
how do you sell
the entire state of California?
A lot of our growth
is grassroots ‐‐
it's through the teachers ‐‐
and that is part
of their persona.
They want to be known
as the techie teacher.
Cuban: You help brand
the teachers.
So they'll go and buy it
out of their own pocket.
Ahh.
They'll figure out
some way to pay for it.
It helps them.
Once it's in the classroom,
it grows on its own.
Wow.
Shane, it's amazing
what you're doing,
but you just gave the challenge
for the company.
How do you scale that?
I mean, how big do you think you
can be in two or three years?
Cox: I'm projecting,
by the end of the year,
we'll be about $650,000
in sales.
How are you gonna get from
$177,000 so far this year to...
So, it's ‐‐ it's the schools
that have bought it,
so the first half
of the year,
these were all schools
that were saying,
"We're gonna buy one or two
of these to test it out,"
with a plan to buy
a lot more in the fall.
So in Texas, for example...
Of all those teachers
you sold one ball to,
how many have come back
and ordered more?
Yeah,
a big chunk of them.
It's not ‐‐
it's not the teacher,
it's ‐‐ I get calls back
from the school,
from the principal now
saying,
"Hey, one of my teachers
got these. I want more."
So, we have a
global cybersecurity company.
We really don't sell
to a lot of school boards
or governments because the
sales process is just so hard.
I'm gonna be old and gray
by the time this thing scales.
I'm sorry, I'm out.
♪♪
What are you gonna
use the money for, Shane?
For me, it's inventory.
Right now, I haven't sold more
because I keep running out.
I haven't been able to do
a consistent marketing push,
'cause I get product,
it's gone,
and then I'm waiting ‐‐
I've got to use that money
to buy the next batch,
I'm waiting for more to come in.
Well, here's my question ‐‐
can you use it with a Polycom?
Yeah, so, it's ‐‐ again,
it's just a standard audio out.
I can't stand
when I am sitting ‐‐
and this is all day long ‐‐
in a conference call
with people, and I'm like,
"Can you move close
to the Polycom?"
Uh‐huh.
"I can't hear you.
I can't hear you."
‐Yes.
‐It drives me bonkers.
I see a huge corporate side
to this.
Every office should have this.
So instead of huddling
around the speakerphone...
Cuban: Have you done
any of that ‐‐ Have you done
any corporate sales yet?
We've done a little bit.
We haven't really focused
anything in that area.
'Cause that seems like
a much bigger opportunity.
And a much easier sale.
I mean,
part of it was I ‐‐ I...
Silicon Valley,
are you kidding me?
There's a lot of different
markets that we can do for this.
I just didn't want to go in
too many different directions.
I kind of love it.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
♪♪
If another Shark would like
to go in with me.
I'll go in.
I'm in.
So now you've got three.
I got three. Whoo!
That's what I like.
Three's good.
Okay?
But you know what that means.
‐Means more equity.
‐It means more equity!
But ‐‐ but...
But you are getting
a powerhouse.
You get a powerhouse.
Let's see...
Everybody huddle.
♪♪
Okay.
I'm gonna say "yeah."
All right, Shane.
Yes.
We're ready for you.
This is a big one,
buddy.
Cox: All right.
So, it's gonna be me
with Mark with Rohan.
The dream team.
$300,000 for 30%.
For 30%.
♪♪
I think you have
a terrific idea here,
but I think that
the experience that, you know,
we could bring
is how to take this
from a vision standpoint
to a much larger platform.
Um...part of me,
just as a businessperson,
I can't not counter.
[ Chuckles ]
So...
Corcoran: You're not ‐‐
you're not interested
in hearing any other offers
on the table?
Barbara's still in.
I love you Barbara,
but...
‐Don't say you're out.
‐[ Laughs ]
But the powerhouse
is just the powerhouse.
It's just three versus one,
it's a...
Shane, you have an offer.
♪♪
I‐If you would do it for 25%.
Look, I respect the fact
that you countered,
but three for one, you don't get
that chance very often.
♪♪
It's a deal.
Done.
‐Whoo!
‐Good move.
[ Laughs ]
Great job, man.
Thank you so much.
Shane, this is gonna solve
all my problems.
‐I‐I'm ordering like...
‐Congratulations.
Oza:
I'm ordering my thing.
30 for all my companies
right off the bat.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, seriously.
‐Get it branded.
‐Seriously, brilliant.
Brilliant.
Congratulations.
[ Sighs ]
Oh, I can't believe it.
[ Chuckles ]
Lori.
Huh?
I get what you're gonna do
with it.
Yeah.
Mark, I get
what you're gonna do with it.
Rohan, you gonna create
a drink out of it?
Look, he's just jelly
'cause he ‐‐
he dropped out...
He's just jelly.
...'cause all he saw
was education.
And we're, like, bro,
there's a much bigger picture.
Proud of you.
You're so smart.
No, I'm not.
You are!
You worked so hard.
Thanks, mom.
So proud of you.
All right.
Okay. All right.
Okay? We got this? Okay?
[ Both singing indistinctly ]
[ Laughing ] Okay.
All right, Mom.
[ Beeps ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is an app
to help make traveling easier.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Ryan Diew,
and I'm the creator of Trippie,
the go‐to app
for navigating big airports.
I'm seeking $100,000 in exchange
for 10% equity in my company.
Airports are confusing,
even for the most frequent
business traveler.
As a college student
from Oakland,
going to school back east
at Colgate,
and a former traveling
Division I basketball player,
I was always in the airport.
My typical airport experience
always went
a little something
like this ‐‐
I'd have my carry‐on bags...
[ Grunts ]
...I'd make my way
all the way to my gate,
then I want to grab a bite
to eat before my long flight,
but I had no idea
which way to turn for food.
And you ‐‐ and you know
how it is ‐‐
an airport directory
is literally never there
when you need it,
and who wants to travel
all the way up and down
the terminal
in search for something
that might not be there
in the first place?
So, sadly, what I had to do
a lot of the time
is settle for the
little newsstand by my gate
that was notorious for selling
nothing but bottled water
and a soggy, disgusting
tuna fish sandwich.
‐Mm.
‐[ Laughs ]
Little did I know that
my favorite Mexican food spot
was only a three‐minute walk
away from my gate.
With Trippie,
I wouldn't have to settle
for this disgusting, nasty
tuna fish sandwich.
Greiner: Oh!
Cuban: Oh! There goes
that basketball career.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Great.
So I started Trippie.
I'm sorry.
Instead, I'd be able to eat the
sumptuous burrito of my dreams.
Herjavec: Yeah.
Trippie takes the guesswork
and turbulence
out of navigating big airports.
Now let me show you
how it works.
Great.
So, you're able
to select an airport.
So, let's select
Shark Tank International.
As you can see, you can get
a list of all the restaurants...
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
Kevin O'Leary Fish.
So, right now,
let's, uh, select,
uh...Shark Tank Diner.
All right.
This is ‐‐
at the Shark Tank Diner,
it's only a minute,
108 feet away.
Where ‐‐
where deals are made.
The top dish
is the Mr. Wonderful Special...
Oza: Ugh, really?
...which features
extreme dilution.
That place is probably closed
by now.
[ Laughter ]
It went out of business.
Food safety.
And so, now, you can see
where you are currently
in the airport and it shows
that that little blue dot
is your location
and it can guide you
all the way to your destination.
With the arrival of Trippie
means the departure
of your airport stress.
[ Laughs ]
So, we need your help
in order to get Trippie
in the hands of millions
of jet‐setters worldwide.
Thank you.
Ryan, how many airports
do you have today?
We have four airports
up to this point ‐‐
San Francisco, Atlanta,
Chicago O'Hare, and Toronto.
So, ever since
I graduated three weeks ago,
we actually expanded.
Right now,
we're in nine airports, so...
Ryan, are you still trying
to finish your burrito?
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Go ahead and swallow.
Thank you.
Take a minute.
Swallow, and then keep going.
Ryan, how do you keep your
information always updated ‐‐
the changes in restaurants,
particularly menu items,
pricing?
So, right now,
it's strictly just a description
of exactly what they sell.
So, for example,
if it's a bar,
it will be like, "They sell,
like, certain types of beer,"
but, like, it's not, like,
really as descriptive.
I'm sorry.
I still have this burrito.
‐That's all right.
‐You need some water?
Do you have some water
back there? Go ahead.
‐Yeah.
‐I don't have water back there.
So embarrassing.
Oh, there you go!
There you go.
Oh, my gosh, thank you.
Thank you, Eric.
Wow,
this is so embarrassing.
Ah, we've got time.
It's only the biggest moment
of your life
and you're choking
on a burrito!
But what else could go wrong?
You're literally choking
in the presence...
‐What else could happen?
‐Welcome back.
Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you.
All right.
Ryan,
are you a student now?
Yes ‐‐ well, I actually
just recently just graduated.
Do you have a job?
Congratulations.
Uh, actually I turned ‐‐
I turned down
a couple jobs, opportunities.
I turned down interviews
from Facebook and Google.
I was my school's
Google Student Ambassador.
How do you make money
today?
What do you do
for a living?
So, right now,
this is all that I do.
I'm ‐‐ I literally, like ‐‐
like ‐‐
like can't go two seconds
without thinking about this.
You live at home?
And so, yeah,
I live at home
with my parents.
Who ‐‐ who coded it?
Wait, wait, so...
I‐I'm the ‐‐ I'm the sole
iOS developer for this app.
Good for you.
Oza: Yes.
Oh, good for you, yeah.
How long ago
did you upload it?
So, I uploaded it to the ‐‐
to the App Store ‐‐
App Store in October.
Do you have
any customers?
Yes.
Right now we have only ‐‐
we ‐‐ we have
about 850 downloads
with 160 monthly
active users.
Okay, so, there are other apps
that do this?
Yes.
Right?
So, tell ‐‐
Well, so ‐‐ similar.
Who cares
about the competitors?
Why are you better?
So, basically,
why we're better
is the fact
that our main goal
is not right now trying
to be an airport directory.
Our main goal is to actually
connect air travelers
within the airport, kind of like
a Waze of the indoor space.
So being able
to connect travelers
who are being able to, like ‐‐
TSA wait times.
That's completely different.
‐Yeah, that's ‐‐
‐I mean, that's ‐‐
But isn't Google Maps
doing a lot of that?
Well, the thing is ‐‐
Google Maps
has your destination stuff...
Yes.
...where it will
literally track
where you walk
in the airport.
Yes. W‐We actually use ‐‐
we're actually using
the Google Maps API.
The thing that, like,
differentiates us
between us and Google Maps
is the fact that we're trying
to make a‐a community
of travelers that basically
are able
to communicate
with one another.
Corcoran: Ryan,
let me ask you something ‐‐
if, for example,
you were able to get $100,000...
Yes.
...here in the Tank,
what would you do
with that money?
My "A" priority is
to get a developer
that's better than me,
to be able
to parse flight itineraries,
to be able to load them
into our application.
Wow.
And since I graduated,
our monthly active users
have jumped by 40%.
To what? How many?
169 monthly actives.
Th‐That's ‐‐
That's a throwaway number,
Ryan.
I understand ‐‐
I understand that it's a ‐‐
it's very low.
Are you plugged in some
kind of a back end system ‐‐
a directory
within the airports?
No, we do not.
Oza: And are you adding
manually,
like someone goes there
and gets this data?
How are you getting
the information?
So, basically,
I‐I work with my ‐‐ my brother
who basically helps me with
data aggregation from hours ‐‐
From public websites
and things.
Online.
Exactly, from hours, reviews,
all these things,
and aggregating that
into our back end ‐‐
‐That's tough.
‐And...
Trying to aggregate that data
essentially manually...
Mm‐hmm.
It's manually.
That's hard.
It is.
Why not tie into
the back end airport systems?
Well, because we don't have
connections in the ‐‐
We ‐‐ I haven't reached out
to the airports.
Greiner: You know,
you said something
that I thought
was quite brilliant.
You said you want
to become the Waze for airports.
I personally think,
if you could,
the biggest problem
ever in airports
is not knowing what
that line's gonna be like...
Security.
...when you get there.
Mm‐hmm.
That would be
an amazing home run.
The reason why I didn't come
in here pitching that,
because we don't have
that functionality
in the application yet.
I have a lot of ideas
of where ‐‐
where to take
this application.
No, I totally get that.
I‐I...yes.
I feel your mind
is brilliant,
and you can get there,
but for me,
I like to know something
is already even in the works.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
Unfortunately,
I don't have that rich uncle.
Unfortunately, I d‐‐
I can't raise that friends
and family round.
Herjavec: Hey, Ryan,
don't say that.
Don't say you don't have
that rich uncle.
Don't ‐‐ don't say that.
L‐Look, my dad worked
in a factory,
my mom was
a receptionist.
You just got to deal with
the reality of what you have.
You got to be
more innovative.
That's the beauty
of being an entrepreneur ‐‐
you get to create value.
And then, like ‐‐
and what would ‐‐
Go with what you have.
Don't look at
what you don't have.
The problem with the app
that I see
is there's nothing proprietary
about it.
There's no competitive advantage
to it.
But right now, I haven't had
the opportunity to really...
I don't want to quash
your enthusiasm,
but I'm out.
Oza: A‐And I‐I would add
to that ‐‐
look, you ‐‐ you have smarts,
you have passion.
I think that even if you hadn't
had a ton of downloads,
even if you'd come and said,
"Look, guys, I have a product.
I haven't gone
out there yet,
but the product has
something proprietary to it,"
I would be open
to that.
My problem is,
at the moment,
the money you need
is to get to the product
that's necessary...
Right.
...so for that reason,
I'm also out.
Corcoran: Ryan, don't ‐‐
don't feel discouraged
because there's nothing wrong
with you.
Yeah.
But what we have here
is not yet a business.
We have a confused model.
So it's too early to come in
and ask for an investment.
I'm out.
♪♪
Our main goal right now
is to be able
to build our user base,
to be able to get our users
to be able to use
this application, and ‐‐
Do you realize
how impossible that is?
That ‐‐
And what I said,
do you realize how many apps
have tried to be ubiquitous
so they have enough users
so that the users
can crowdsource information
and make it work,
like Waze have
or like someone else have?
Look, I'm not gonna
over‐compliment you.
I'm not gonna just build you up,
'cause I know this hurts.
And I can see it on your face
how bad it hurts.
We're only
in the iOS store.
We aren't even ‐‐
we haven't even jumped to An‐‐
my mom can't even download
the application.
How many people in Toronto
use their airport?
About ‐‐
about 20 million a year.
Okay. How many people live
in San Francisco and use SFO?
San Francisco, who use it,
about 55 million a year.
What are
the other airports?
Atlanta,
which is 104 million.
Okay.
Just take those three.
Yes.
Right?
Your potential user base
is over 200 million
people...
Yes.
...and you have
169 monthly active users.
It's not the number
of airports.
As an application
that's in beta,
a lot of people
believe in us.
When we pitched
last year at Colgate,
when this was just an idea,
we had three Forbes 30 Under 30
CEOs that believed ‐‐
Ryan, you're lying to yourself
to think
that you're gonna be
so differentiated
that everybody's gonna
ignore iOS Maps
and Google Maps
and come to you.
I'm so‐‐ I'm sorry.
I get this is hard.
It's hard
to be an entrepreneur.
I'm saying this to you
to try to help.
The one mistake
almost every entrepreneur makes
that we have to overcome
is we lie to ourselves.
We tell ourselves
that it's a great idea.
The problem with your idea
is it's a feature,
not a product.
I hope you get there,
but I'm out.
I wish you the best, bud.
Thank you.
Good luck.
Hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on.
I just have to say
one thing.
Hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on.
I just have to say
one thing.
I know, like ‐‐
I put my blood, sweat,
and tears into this.
I have done this while being
a‐a college basketball player,
while being a ‐‐ b‐being
a full‐time
computer science major,
a student,
a‐a‐a leader on campus ‐‐
all these things,
I've been able
to do all this
in the back
of the bus on the ‐‐
after away games.
When we were traveling
back from D. C.,
I'm coding.
In the airport before games,
Ryan, you know what?
Stop patting yourself
on the back,
and stop feeling sorry
for yourself.
I've spent 36 hours straight
coding,
teaching myself
different langua‐‐
so has Robert,
so has Barbara.
It's part of the deal!
Accept that hard work,
struggle, and sacrifice
is part of being
an entrepreneur!
Don't feel sorry for yourself!
Go get the job done!
I'm not patting myself
on the back.
I'm just telling you my ‐‐
I'm telling you my story.
You're gonna go
in the real world!
It's about investing
in the entrepreneur.
in the entrepreneur
as much as the product.
I understand ‐‐
Ryan.
No, I ‐‐
You identified a need.
You've got to create
a real product
and a real business!
Ryan, go ahead
and prove us wrong.
You know how many times I've
been called wrong and an idiot?
And every single one
of those times,
it's maybe hundreds of millions
if not billions of dollars.
‐Right.
‐You just got to go prove it.
‐I guess what ‐‐
‐But you have to have a product
before you can do that.
♪♪
Good luck, Ryan.
We wish you the best.
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
Painful.
Woof.
Cuban: You want
a participation trophy!
I don't want to say that
this is a Millennial stereotype,
but it sure feels like
a Millennial stereotype.
He thought he had a winner.
He came with a winner,
he got some tough love,
and then he broke down.
♪♪
[ Voice breaking ]
It was so bad.
Ohh...
Dude, they ‐‐
they thought that I was
this entitled, like, kid.
But, like, I was...
Ohh...
[ Sobs ]
Sweetheart.
This is so emba‐‐
no, this is so embarrassing.
I'm gonna ‐‐ this ‐‐
Why? Why?
It's not ‐‐ look, look, look,
look, look, look, look.
This is so embarra...
No, you know what?
This is so ‐‐ dude,
this is so embarrassing, Mom.
Like, honestly.
Like, this is ‐‐ that was bad.
They just kind of just ‐‐
just pooped on ‐‐
like, pooped on it bad.
I've never seen you
so invested in anything
in my entire life.
No, no, no,
we're not doing this.
This is motivation.
We're gonna dig down.
We're gonna
get back in the lab,
and we're gonna
make it happen.
You're not just gonna
quit your dream.
♪♪